>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Well, good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen and welcome to the African
and Middle East Division
of the Library of Congress.
Today's lecture on Muslimism
and Turkey and Beyond,
Religion in the Modern World
by Neslihan Cevik is sponsored
by the near East section of the
African and Middle East division.
I'm Joan Weeks, head of
the near East section.
On behalf of all my colleagues
and in particular Dr. Mary Jane
Deech, chief of the division.
I'd like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
Before we start today's program I'd
like to give you a brief overview
of the division and its resources
in the hopes that you'll come back
and use our collections
for your research.
This division is comprised
of three sections that build
and serve collections to the
researchers from around the world.
We cover over 78 countries
for more than 35 languages.
The African section
includes the countries
in all of sub-Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic section is responsible
for tuderica and Hebraica worldwide.
And the near East section covers
all of the Arab countries,
including North Africa, Turkey,
Iran, Afghanistan, Central Asia,
the Muslims in western China,
Russia, and the Balkans,
and the people of the Caucasus.
So you can see we're very busy.
After the program we like to invite
you to fill in the evaluation forms
that we've left in your
seats and leave them
at the information desk
at the back of the room.
And we are videotaping and recording
this presentation, so we invite you
to ask questions, but please know
that you're providing your
permission to be recorded.
Now, I would like to introduce
our speaker, Dr. Neslihan Cevik.
She is an associate fellow at the
Institute for Advanced Studies
in Culture at the University
of Virginia.
Currently Dr. Cevik is leading the
project on the deradicalization
and fight against violent
extremism at the organization
of Islamic cooperation, the OIC.
Her work appears in CNN
Arabic, Daily Savant, Orient 21
and Political Theology
Today and is translated
into Arabic, French, and Turkish.
Dr. Cevik helped found the first
postcolonial studies research center
in Turkey, Palmer Atascadero
University.
An engaged social entrepreneur,
she also leads startup projects
from Muslim women's economic
and public integration.
Please help welcome Dr.
Cevik to the podium.
>> Thank you.
[ Clapping ]
>> Thank you Dawn for this lovely
introduction and thank you Mary Jane
and John for inviting me here.
This is a mesmerizing,
very beautiful building,
so and thank you each and every
one of you for coming here today.
So I should put my
presentation up, okay.
Slide show, okay, so
I'm going to start --
I will start by raising
a very old question.
A question that was actually
central to the development
of sociology and social theory.
So what happens to religion
in the modern world?
How do religions response
to modernity?
And for centuries the answer
read along a very binary track,
so in their responses to
modernity religions were expected
to either reject it, and that's
what we call fundamentalism,
to preserve the tradition or they
would secularize the tradition
and accommodate modernity and that's
what we call liberal religion.
And even though this binary
track was mostly based
on the Christian experience,
it's also applied to Islam,
but when it's applied to Islam it's
a little bit modified given the
perception of Islam as a
special religion, which is --
that Islam is intrinsically
anti-modern
and intrinsically secularization
resistant.
So given this the divide
and modifies into the idea
that Islam gears towards
rejection of modernity
and Islamic fundamentalism
or Islamic rejection
of modernity itself is geared
towards politically takeover
of the state.
So accordingly then if Islam is
to engage modernity it
must loosen orthodoxy more
than any other religion while
also making a cultural turn.
So that also created yet another
divide, cultural versus political.
And this kind of framework,
this kind of abstract framework
crystallized into the concept
of moderate Islam more
recently and turkey is picked
as the most prominent
candidates for it.
And the concept has been helpful
to some extent in communicating
that Islam needs not
to reject modernity,
but actually can engage it.
But there are various problems
with the concept moderate Islam.
First of all, it reinforces
the divide of fundamentalist
versus a liberal religion, because
radical moderation of Islam happens
through the pacification
of its radical aspects.
So meaning that the practice of
moderate is something less Islamic
and more liberal than the norm.
So apparently this marginalizes
any deeply held religion
and it simply has religion
actually must be fundamentalist.
Also another problem with the
term is that the conditions
for moderate Islam
is constantly being
or at least mostly is being looked
out from outside, rather
than from within.
And most interpretations
rely on political expediency
and political actors in trying to
understand how moderation happens.
But there's a serious
problem with that
because party failure is
then seen as Islam's failure
in engaging modernity and the Arab
spring was probably the epic example
of that.
The cultural sentiments
that could not translate
into political change were
that interpreted again,
yet again as Islam's failure
into engaging modern
life and institutions.
But most importantly the concept
of moderate Islam prevents us
from seeing the empirical
complexities of religion in Turkey,
but also about more broadly
Islam's engagements of modernity.
So in my book, "Looking at Post
80's Islamic Transformation
of Islamic Identity in
Turkey," I argued that's rather
than normatively or
generically defining what's going
on as moderate Islam, what
we're witnessing is the rise
of any religious form, indeed
in your religious orthodoxy.
And when I say "in orthodoxy,"
I don't mean the separation
between orthodoxy of an
orthopractic religions.
I simply denote a commitment
to the super empirical,
but this orthodoxy is new
because it's neither fundamentalist
rejection of modernity,
nor liberal submission to it.
Indeed within the Turkish context
I call this new form Muslimism
and I argue that this new form
embraces aspects of modern life,
while submitting that life to
a sacred moral order generating
as such hybrid institutions,
discourses and lifestyles
and we will kind of
unpack these as we go.
Now, why the term "Muslimism"?
First of all, this new form looking
at a liberal nor fundamentalist
required a new category.
Normally, you know, Islamism
is used as a term is used
as an umbrella term to define
any Islamic movement that kind
of promotes Islam,
whether in public policy
or true politics or
in everyday life.
But even if it's being used
as an umbrella term,
it's not a neutral term.
I mean, it has a very
specific [inaudible] baggage
that it brings with it.
So and other scholars too looking
at the world has recognized
that since the 1990's and
'80s Islamic movements started
to look not like the
typical Islamism.
And so they looked for
alternative concepts.
Moderate Islam was one of them plus
Islamism, Muslim hood, neo-Islamism,
but I think what we find in
Turkey requires a very clear break
from the concept of Islamism,
so that's the first reason
that I wanted to term
this with a new label.
Also I wanted this term
to communicate the
content of this new form.
Now, so one key element of
this new form that its hybrid.
It doesn't reject nor submits,
but it creates hybrid
institutions and practices.
And the other key element is
that it's individual orientation.
So basically the question
Muslims must ask is,
"How do I conduct a pious life
while taking part in modernity?"
And so there neither state
oriented nor society oriented.
The goal isn't Islamization
of the state from top-down
or nor it is Islamization
of the community bottom
up to eventually create
an Islamic state.
And this is not individualism.
I found something even more
interesting in the field
that this was actually filtered
through geological concepts,
particularly Iman and Tahqiq.
We're going to talk about those
in detail later, but it's suffice
for now just to quickly define,
Iman simply means to volunteer
in a heartfelt choice
its religious conviction.
And Tahqiq is a conscious choice .
Again, I'll unpack these later.
So even though Muslimism
is not a formal movement,
and it's not ideological,
it still is an ism.
For one, it capitalizes and promotes
a particular reading of Islam
and it promotes this
reading again Islamism
and against liberal conceptions
and against actually
traditional conceptions.
And although it's not state
centered, its politically engaged.
It gets linked to party politics
and it has created a very
certain political ethos.
So before I detail the
content of this new form,
I want to briefly talk about the
conditions and open questions.
We can unpack these.
I'm going to go through
this kinda quickly.
So this new form is rooted in the
1980s neo-liberalizing policies.
This was a neo-liberalization in
Turkey was more than economic shift,
it actually created a favorable
atmosphere for religious change
and for the emergence of
alternative religious expressions.
First of all, it undermined
statism across spheres of society,
so an economy and culture
in social reproduction.
And this allowed for a new economic
and political opportunity spaces
for Muslim mobilization and
those segments he [inaudible]
to until the 1980's
were marginalized,
both from economic production and
social and political production.
And other scholars
have recognized this,
but what's kinda often overlooked is
that new liberalization also brought
with it a new social
accounting of modernity.
With the secular state
modernity so far
until the 1980s were defined
along secularist conceptions,
whether your hijab or not,
whether you're religious or not,
corporatism, statism, but with the
new liberal order new conceptions
started to enter into social
accounting of modernity,
like individual rights, pluralism,
globalization, entrepreneurship.
And so these two kinda like low
modernity and high modernity started
to compete with each other
and that was very important
because it seriously taunt down the
anti Islam concept of or rhetorical
for modernity that was generated
by the camelists, the secular state
and it allowed the Muslim
populations, the devout populations
to reconsider aspects of modernity
and to reconsider engagements,
their engagements with modernity.
And all of that also worked to
weaken Islamists establishments,
because in Turkey Islamism has
emerged in the mirror image
of the secularist state
that defined modernity,
that define national progress,
that defined individual progress
in the opposite of Islam.
So basically it created
a sound forbidden modern,
but with the new liberalization
the conditions
that generated Islamism got weakened
and as a result Islamism is a
discourse started to lose its appeal
and economic and cultural
and political relevance.
And the international
aspects are also conducive
for derisive Muslimism.
They were coupled with
the domestic conditions.
Let's go through this.
So new liberalization also
created the agents of Muslimism
and it created more
specifically a Muslim city group
and this group is composed of
people coming from, you know,
spheres of society, veiled
university students, professionals,
technocrats, entrepreneurs,
civil activists and so forth.
And they're educated,
urbanized and upwardly mobile
and they used the universal
language of rights
than globalization and so forth.
So they're not marginal to
modern life, but they were all
of the integrated into modern life
while seeking a higher control
over it.
And this new Muslim city group
engaged modern contemporary life
by using Islam creating what I call
the cultural sites of hybridity,
which is where, you know,
the Muslims form emerges.
Now the Muslims -- the cultural
size of hybridity first emerged
in the markets in the form
of business situations
that engaged aspect of capitalism
while trying to inject moral codes
or morally regulate capitalism,
but it also included some
really controversial sides,
such as Islamic passion.
Although, rather than fashion I
prefer to call it personalization
of aesthetics of the
hijab, but we're going
to talk about that later.
They're also emerge Islamic
vacations and hotels.
The picture to my right probably
is to your left all the way
to the left, it's a picture
from the first Islamic hotel
that was open in Turkey
back in 1990.
It's a pool for women only, so
but beyond markets the sites
of hybridity also included
character education schools
that emphasized inner discipline
and character over orthopraxy.
It included human rights
associations who defined rights
in reference to both
to UN convention
and the Medina Certificate the
farewell speech of Prophet Mohammed.
It included women's rights
organizations who claim at religious
and Islamic identity, but
also a democrat identity.
And it wasn't only the
cultural arena that we
so decides emerging the Muslim
city group is also articulated
in the political ethos, which
sees Islamic and modern values not
to be incommensurable, but actually
complementing towards each other.
And in particular again, we're going
to talk about this, but the concepts
of Iman and Tahqiq within the
Muslimists discourse leads the
Muslim is to define the state
with a liberal framework
and we're going to
talk about that more.
And in addition to the political
ethos Muslimists get linked
to party politics to
bring about this ethos,
so this isn't just
the cultural movement.
I mean, it engages politics and
it has political consequences.
But for markets to the political
era now, what we see happening
in cultural sites of hybridity is
that these are sites
of identity production.
They resist the hegemony of the
secular state on defining modernity
and how to be modern, and they
resist the hegemony of Islamism
on defining true religion
and who is a good Muslim.
More broadly they defined
modernity to be guilt free,
so modernity is no
longer reduced to some
of evil effects destroying
the Muslim consignees
and Islamic sensibilities.
For example, you can have a
pluralistic public sphere,
but you can still have
faithful individuals.
And they also redefined
Islam to be on --
not redefined, but revitalized
faith to be unapologetic.
One can be faithful and still
promote a pluralistic public sphere
or dress like Grace Kelly
as long as you know she is
within the boundaries
of the orthodoxy.
So here is some info
on my field research.
I'm kinda going, you know,
to past this if there are
questions we can go back,
but basically I interviewed
the leaders of --
I picked up political area,
human rights organizations,
business organizations, and
woman's rights organizations,
and I interviewed and ethnography
observations with the leaders
from the congressman
and woman to sectortures
of the business associations to
leaders of human rights activists.
So to precisely understand what the
Muslimists discourse is I used the
infamous treaties, which DIN, DUNYA,
DEVLET religion world and state.
And I further looked
at reality orientations
in [inaudible] ontology,
agency, and action.
For example, how do I read religion?
What does religion mean to me?
What does the good state mean to me?
And who am I assigning
agency to establish
that view and to maintain it?
And what kind of action I think
is appropriate for us to maintain
that kind of [inaudible]?.
So I compared Islam is the
Muslims elements with each other
to basically communicate the newness
and innovation of Muslims form,
but I'm not redefining Islamism
is basically coming from the work
that was previously done on it.
So normally what I do in my talks
is I go through different cells,
but today given today's
importance is woman's day I wanted
to do something different.
First of all, I will introduce
data about how Muslims formulate
to self and the community.
The Muslim ulma, and I want
to talk about our focus
on the particular role played
by women in formulation
of the conceptions of
self and community.
And I'm going to use fashion
as a side of [inaudible]
to kinda demonstrate how
these transformations happen.
Now, there a lot of stigmas about
Islam out there and one of them is
that Islamic theology is marked by
authoritarian communal attitudes.
It's a communitarian
authoritarian religion
that violates the individual
and her or his self-expression.
Now, indeed this isn't necessarily
interesting to Islam, but the two
but this is something that's
formulated by Islamist movements
and Islamist intellectual thought.
And in fact, within itself it's
quite coherent and quite rational.
Now, Islamists are focused on
preserving the pristine religion,
however they define it
and to preserve pristine
religion they define an
authoritarian community.
Basically the community
has authoritative harbor
over the individuals and that is
so that the community
can keep individuals
with incorrect moral action and
pristine codes, because without
that control individuals may reach
moral boundaries so individual
and the self-expression is seen
as threats to the shared purity
of Islam and social cohesion.
And in order to keep individuals
within the correct moral action
Islamists also focus on orthoproxy,
meaning the ritualistic aspects
of religion, especially the ones
by which one can be
recognized as a Muslim.
And the first thing that
comes to mind is the hijab.
So for Islamists the Islamists try
to prescribe how the
hijab should be worn.
It's not only that you
have to wear the hijab,
but also the ways you're
supposed to wear the hijab
and those prescriptions tend
to be determined by men,
so that also means at the local
level, whether it's community
or family man policies and
limits women's moral agency.
So then you look at Muslimism,
you see a radically
different formulation
of the self and community.
We see that these traditional
conceptions are being transformed
and the direction
of this transformation is towards
the sharpening of the individual
and the undermining
of a authoritarian
communal religious codes.
And fashion I know when I say
"fashion," it constantly, you know,
brings those images about
[inaudible] and about consumerism
and about markets is as if
it's a [inaudible] place,
but bear with me it's
going to surprise you.
So hijab and fashion
is a very proper angle
to kinda trace have those
changes are happening.
So when I was talking to women
in the field about various things
from liberal state and
theology to fashion,
overwhelmingly they were talking,
they were really reactionary
against Islamist and
traditional conceptions.
Most of them said looking
back at their college years,
so these women were in their
maybe late 30's or early 40's
and looking back to college years,
they were saying back in the 80s'
and 90's we were not able to cover
an expression of who we were,
because the colors, you
know, dark brown, black,
dark black or dark green.
And in terms of styles too it was
very monotype, so they weren't able
to cover an expression
of who they were.
See, it wasn't about, oh,
yeah, we couldn't be trendy.
We wanted to look more fashionable.
It wasn't about that.
It was about expressing
who they were.
And so they would criticize both
the traditional establishments
and the Islamists for
trying to format the veil.
In fact, they had a name for
this era of 80's and early 90's.
They called it the Uniform
Era, where the hijab was seen
as a uniform, but they were saying,
but look, women are not uniformed.
We're different from each other.
How are we different
from each other?
Well, some of us are
15, some of us are 50's,
some of us are tall,
some of us are short.
Some of us have outgoing
personalities,
some of us like black,
some of us don't.
Some of us are married,
some of us are single,
so and we have different tastes and
we have different personalities.
And so they wanted to
cover an expression of all
of those unique individual features.
So, for example, this female
from [inaudible] Platform said,
"Initially the tessettur attire,
tessettur means Islamic covering
or some clothing was a
uniform and now we sort
of got out of the uniform era.
But in Turkey the veiling
styles are still monotype.
Plus there is the age factor.
Why would a 60-year-old
woman and a 15-year-old girl
where the same things, tie their
scarf similarly or use same colors?"
Another woman was saying, "How many
veiled woman we have is how many
types of veil we have.
I believe that veiling style
is just like dressing style.
Some women believe that veiled
people represent each other
and Muslims with colorful outfits
misrepresent other veiled women.
This totalization comes both
from inside and outside.
They try to stigmatize
us and confine us
within a political discourse."
So, but why is it important
that these women want
to cover an expression
of who they are?
I mean, what is that tell us?
Well, it portends those changes
that I was talking about.
First, the self has
found the new legitimacy
and interest among the Muslimists
and that challenges the
Islamist homogenity,
the idea of the community
being authoritarian
and self being illegitimate
and self being a threat.
Second, self-styled replace
prescriptions, and again,
those prescriptions are on mostly
defined by men, so buy self styling
or personalizing there hijab the
colors or whatever the styles,
they're actually exercising moral
agency on their body because it's,
you know, it's how you dress.
And then now we have moral agency
in defining what's appropriate,
so what's the moral
boundaries that I have to abide
by as I, you know, cover myself?
And what's also the limits
about me expressing myself?
So that challenge patriachal codes.
Now for many this will be seen as,
you know, the explanation for this,
how did this happen it
probably will follow
if there's stereotypical
[inaudible].
Okay, this is market expansion,
its individualism via consumerism,
but what I found and that
was even more interesting was
that this process was neither
related to individualism,
nor it was freed from God.
Now, we're going to delve
a little bit into theology
and you will see why I think
fashion is a fascinating phenomena
or aspect of our lives.
So this legitimacy of the self was
indeed filtered through the grammar
of faith and core theological
concepts,
Iman and Tahqiq, particularly.
So linguistically Iman means being
sure of something, certainty,
being in a state of security.
In the chronic usage it means
unshakable convention binding one's
heart to Allah and it's
a heartfelt submission.
So it's this voluntary heartfelt
submission or love of God.
And the locus of Iman
then is the heart
and this wasn't only the
Muslimists discourse,
I mean it's not an
innovation by Muslimists.
It's the illusions early
theologians and scholars coming
from different theological
streams, which at time conflict
with each other, such as Maturidi,
Taftanzani, Ibn hazm, Al-Ghazali,
all of those scholars also so
Iman's location to be the heart.
Now this is important, focus
on Iman is very important.
Think about it this way.
If I was an Islamist, if I
had a [inaudible] with me
and if I raise the [inaudible] and I
told all the women in the audience,
"You got to cover your
hair right now."
Or from the reverse I
may be a secularists
and [inaudible] extremely
annoyed by the veil
and I may take the
[inaudible] and say,
"All of you take your
hijabs off right now."
And I could've even require
you for my public policy to not
to come school, to not to work
because you're wearing a hijab.
But as a state or as any authority
I cannot and actual law asking all
of the [inaudible]
to love God by heart
or I cannot enact a law
telling the citizens from now
on you stop loving God, because
heart cannot be controlled
by external sources of authority.
And that's where the
legitimacy of the self
within the Muslims discourse comes.
It's rooted in theological
retrieval of the concept of Iman.
Now there's more.
When religion is a voluntary choice,
it also becomes a conscious choice,
and overwhelmingly both men
and women in my interviews
as they define true piety and said
that it's true piety Iman they
were also talking about tahqiq
and tahqiq basically
means investigation.
So basically one needs to ask
what is it that I believe and why?
So religion isn't something or
mature faith isn't something
that just happens to you
by virtue of, you know,
borning in a community,
in a religious community
doesn't make your faith mature.
Instead you have to
deliberate infer rather
than blindly submitting
to inherited knowledge.
And tahqiq is a means centered
concept as much as ends directed.
It's about what tahqiq questions,
but it's also the tact
of tahqiq itself.
Now, all of that within the
Muslimists discourse then presents
us with a self with potent
agency and that absolutely goes
against Islamism and if you think
about Isis today, it
makes so much sense.
So moral action should flow
within the Muslims discourse
from the heartfelt and
conscious submission and choice.
So moral agency and autonomy
it gives the self moral agency
and autonomy vis-à-vis
external authority.
And this is not rejection
of communal experience.
It's not individualization.
It's not rejection of
communal experience,
but it's simply individuation.
So marking one's difference.
Self actualization, an expression
self-expression in rejection
of oppressive communities
that see the self as a threat.
So Muslims then transform
the Muslim umma or the idea
of community conservatively
into a type of sodality
where there's still
strongly committed
to a moral community a common
good and a shared identity,
but they at the same time
require that community
to acknowledge the self, to
acknowledge the unique traits
of the self and the individual
choice preference and difference.
So another woman in relation to
what I've just argued was saying,
talking about the cemaats, you know,
the informal religious networks,
that were commensurate with an
authoritarian style of community.
Throughout the 1980's the
religious scene was dominated
by cemaats and tricots.
People couldn't even take one
step independent of the cemaats.
They would follow whatever
the head of the cemaats says.
By then also if you were religious
or veiled people would expect you
to have or accept certain
rules and ideas.
By the 1990's she continues this
change then people became more
individualized in terms
of being able to act
and decide independently.
This is how I view
the CBPA platform,
so this woman quits the cemaats and
then joins this woman's association.
And then she says "Here woman
are not tied to anywhere.
This is why I decided
to become a member.
Woman here are women who are able
to realize this individualization.
They have different and creative
ideas they can express these
different before you couldn't
even think about that."
So going back to self styling
and fashion, so the importance
of covering an expression of who
one is and that's basically based on
or filtered through this,
you know, broader movements
where within theology Aql
and tahqiq, meaning reason
and investigation and Iman start to
compete with traditional knowledge
and conformity to community.
So that also gives us cues about
how the Muslimists view the self.
Now let me make a [inaudible].
For the Islamists, both are
Muslimists and Islamists.
The self is something
tricky because, you know,
the self is always
vulnerable to the seductions
of the [inaudible] of the devil.
For Islamists, however,
the self is so weak
that it requires an external
authority to keep him within,
you know, correct moral actions,
whether that be the
state or the community.
So in order to create a
religiously defined society
and faithful individuals that
needs to be an external authority.
And sin according to Islamists, is
not necessarily a personal choice.
It's the seduction of the devil,
seduction of the [inaudible].
Now for Muslimists this
is a little different.
For Muslimists, remember
that, you know,
concentration on Iman you are
responsible as an individual
to choose between permissible
and impermissible deeds
and indeed that's how
you're going to be judged.
The self is still vulnerable
to [inaudible]
but the self [inaudible] fight
it's the personal hijab to fight
against the [inaudible] and then
to keep itself away
from the impermissible.
And you got to do that whether
there's a [inaudible] that's telling
you that or not.
So in another aspect of this
is that for the Muslimists,
the Islamic self is someone
who's a critical thinker,
intellectually curious
and she's creative.
It questions established
codes and receive knowledge
in a conservative hierarchy.
And she or he is not seeing
the adult image of community,
but has its own differences unique
assets and traits and, you know,
self styling of hijab is just
one practical example of that.
There's a long [laughs] codes.
I'm not going to read all of it,
but basically this course speaks
into what I just described.
A human rights activist female
says, "When I was confronted
for the first time with the
ban on veil in college."
So she was wearing
a hijab in Turkey.
There was a ban on hijab.
You couldn't go to university.
" I realize that traditional
religiosity didn't mean anything.
I had a faith that come
from tradition by then.
Then I stopped all of my readings
and started reading Kuran.
What I believe in and why.
Is the veil really an order
of Allah or is it nonsense?
Allah has given us aql, reason
and intellect and the skills
and capacity for reasoning.
It says in the Kuran
are you not thinking?
Are you not using your aql?"
So as you can see this kind of
speaks into the ideal conception
of the self within Muslimist
community, being, you know,
someone who questions,
someone who goes back
to the original resources
and think for herself.
Kind of like try to
dig out the truth.
Now, fashion isn't the only area
where we find this changing
conception of self and community.
Another area we find it
is religious learning
and sources of religious authority.
What we find in Turkey is that
increasingly there's a shift from,
you know, the charismatic the
[inaudible] elite to the Alim.
The Alim is basically
the religious scholar,
so our people are increasingly
turning towards the Alim
for their religious learning
and because this is something
we find very clearly am
on the Muslimists and they think of
Alim as they kind of cherish Alim
because they say that he establishes
his vocational relationship
through formal education
through studio's work.
And he is an intellectual
he's an autonomous thinker,
he is almost comparable
to a scientist.
And as you can see this kind
of embodies the most ideal
version of the Muslimist itself.
And importantly Alim is not
someone to be followed blindly,
so when you're reading a book
or when you're discussing
with a scholar you're not expect
to politely submit to this person
as opposed to, you know,
a head of a cemaat.
You still have the critical distance
between yourself and the author as
or the guide and the mentor and
then you still have to like decide
for your own and then dig
the truth of for yourself.
And as this women rights of
female activist speaks into that
and she says "Not everybody can
be a doctor or a sociologist.
We must have Alims we trust
and we learn from, however,
this must not be in
the form of being tied
to one person or following a cemaat.
You read the books and works of
these Alim and you evaluate these
through your aql, your
reason, and your evaluation."
Another area we see the rising
of the self and the undermining
of the community is
traditional family.
And this is kind of where it
gets tricky because the quest
for the self and self autonomy
goes both for men and women,
but when it comes to family, I found
that there were some gendered lines.
Basically, within the family women
had to pick an additional battle
in their quest for self autonomy.
I mean, this is, you know,
kind of very typical,
not just Islam and Turkey.
We have it, you know, maybe
every part of the world,
so basically women were
talking about how the definition
of womanhood around motherhood
and wifehood is a problem,
because this doesn't allow them
to discover who they really are.
Again, in parentheses this is
the legitimacy of the self.
It's legitimate to be interested in
the self to discover who you are.
I mean, within the
Islamist perception
of community, this is an irrelevant.
And so basically those patriarchal
codes and relations worked
as barriers in the eyes of the woman
to develop their self-identity.
And I asked him a question.
I was like "So do you mind your
daughter to live, you know,
before she gets married to
live by herself for some time?"
And women, maybe like one or
two, except one or two women ,
ike 30 woman said, "Absolutely."
And the reason why they said
because they were like, okay,
so the father's house and the
husband's house are places where,
you know, woman cannot really
develop their self-identity
and develop life strategies and,
you know, get to know themselves
and establish their independency.
So this doesn't mean that
they're like feminists.
I mean, they're still, you know,
promote this idea of, you know,
marriage and that's still a
very important institution.
They're not against obviously,
I mean they're, you know,
sacrilegious people, but may
be, I mean it's interesting,
maybe this is living by
themselves before going
into the husband's house, I mean,
maybe that's just a temporary place
for them to kinda like
strengthen themselves
and then go into the marriage.
For men the answer was also
yes, but man was more practical.
They were saying well, you know,
if she want a good university
and that college was out
of town, then she can go.
So it was more like practical
based on practical reasoning rather
than this discourse about
the discovering herself
through developing life
strategies and support.
So this also shows us that woman's
role in creating and disseminating
and shaping the future of Muslimism
is quite important because they had
to catch on this, you
know, gendered issues
and their progressive
from that perspective.
So going back to fashion
a little bit before we,
you know, pack things up.
So fashion also works it's
one area to look at, you know,
one aspect of it we can look at the
changes that's going to in terms
of conceptions of self
and community,
but there's also another aspect
that brings into this, you know,
hybridity back to our attention.
So this is a picture of
the Hashema swimsuits.
The Hashema swimsuit
emerged back in the 1990's.
Basically, you can swim in this.
I actually wore it, took pictures
with it and I met the first producer
of the Hashemas and he's called,
I mean there's an epithet
to define him.
He's called the man who
made Muslim woman swim.
Now, swimming [laughs] may
sound like a very thin exercise,
natural has nothing
to do with politics.
But not really.
I mean, in Turkey swimming
is [inaudible]
at the public beaches are
associated with this, you know,
secular, [inaudible] identity.
Even if you look at the world,
when you say "swimming,"
you know we constantly think
about bikinis and uncovering,
so it's like you can't swim
if you're not uncovered.
But this guy basically rejected
those divides and said you can swing
with you're a Muslim, here, where
my Hashema, and it may not look nice
and it may offend the secular
conscience, because the normality
of swimming is uncovering.
Although, I would like to remind you
that a song about the Polka dots,
Itsy-Bitsy Teeny-Weeny [laughs].
I mean, you know, that emerged
when bikini was first introduced
to the American audience after
friends and one of the magazines
by then defined it no
decent girl would wear this.
But later on few weeks
later, you know,
along with the feminist
moments, you know,
emergence it became the
only way, you know, to swim.
So what's the size of
hybridity and fashion, you know,
in this example does is
that it's kind of turns back
at your face normality
standards we so abide by.
I mean, you don't have
to wear a bikini to swim
and we have many more examples
of this emerging, like,
so I own a hijab conservative
company
and then throughout the company work
I met a lot of interesting people.
For example, this girl she is
one of the first Olympic lifters
and she's a hijab girl
and she was having a lot
of difficulty finding clothing
because when you lift you have
to like put it on your leg
and when you take it up,
it raises whatever you're wearing.
So they were wearing
like really tight sweats,
and that was just not our
purpose for her, so she was like,
well I'm going to go to all
[inaudible] what am I going to wear?
So that's the other thing like we
look at the Muslim world and we say,
yeah, we need more education.
You know, these women need to know
their rights, but honestly even
if they want to go to do,
you know, all them pics,
they don't have clothing for it.
They want to play basketball.
What am I going to wear?
You know, that's quite
important question,
so basically by creating the
Hashema, what this guy has gone was
to create new public
agencies and new possibilities
for Muslims to engage modernity.
So apparently they're
not fundamentalist,
because for an Islamist, you know,
they would say "What
are you talking about?
What swimming, you know,
there's jihad people are dying."
Even actually there was an author
who wrote about the [inaudible]
and he said, "Can you see people
who die in Chechen and Islam
from the beautiful windows
of the [inaudible] hotel?"
So you're going to offers have
these tensions but that doesn't mean
that Muslimist aren't aware of that
or they aren't actively
engaged in that debate.
They are actively engaged
in the public debate.
They are actively politically
engaged.
They get linked to
political parties,
but that's also living life.
So and one last thing.
This also kind of pushes back their
secular and Islamist totalization
of Muslim woman, especially
hijab woman expected
to dress the same way, to walk the
same way, to love the same way,
to live the life the same way.
So it kind of brings out the
diversity of woman and speaks back
into what I was just discussing
earlier about the legitimacy
of the self and the changing
conceptions about the community.
Now this is also an
issue of identity.
This is, first of all, Muslimism is
not unique to Turkey and I will come
to that slide unpack it a little
bit more, but for now I think
into US we find a very
similar process.
The Muslim Mipster moment,
basically of hipster coming together
with Muslim and then you
have the mipster [laughs].
So the mipster is considered
as the third place.
It's where, you know, the house
and the host is blended
towards each other and I think
that third place really
resembles what I called
in Turkey the cultural
sides of hybridity.
You know, it's where you don't
reject modernity, you don't submit
to it, but you kind of
like create this hybridity.
And hipster is someone obviously
nonconformist, politically liberal
and it cherishes the
authenticity of the self.
I mean, that's the main element
and if you look at hijab, you know,
the global stigmas about
it is that it's conformity
to a patriarchal community,
it kills the self,
it colonizes the self
through the community.
So how does a hipster
and a hijab come together
and then this could be a mipster
fashion amidst the culture?
Well, that puzzle is what
the mipster capitalizes,
because they now introduce
the mipster in the US.
They reintroduce themselves as
passionately religious actors,
passionately Muslim people, but
at the very same time already
and rightfully modern and American.
They cherish self authenticity
and naturalness that also
within religious submission
and that also speaks
into my previous discussion
on self becoming legitimate,
the individual becoming legitimate.
And the mipster challenges the
[inaudible] the minds of modernity
versus religion, Islam versus
best or Muslim versus American.
So just I'm going to pack it up.
So why is it important
to understand --
well, take us -- let
me take a step back.
So when we say "Islam
or any religion,"
obviously religions are Orthodoxial
and they have an objective truth
for the faithful and it's not like
as the world changes and the essence
of religion changes,
that's not the case.
But different actors articulate
different expressions of religion.
I mean, you have Islamism,
you have Muslimism,
you have liberal of theology.
It's kind of like a range, and in
the post-80's turkey conditions were
such that this new form
of Muslimism has emerged
and this new form importantly
challenged the divides of modernity
versus religion and
political versus cultural.
And again, as a reminder about
the political versus cultural,
the Muslimists are not
oriented to the state.
They're not after establishing
an Islamic state,
but they have produced a political
efface, so the Iman and tahqiq,
while they push for a community
that recognizes individual agency,
they also push for a
state model that's framed
on the basis of individual rights.
The example I gave about
enacting, you know,
a law that would control
the party can't
and Iman mind is something
that's located in the heart.
So for Muslimists the
tension between moral freedoms
and a secular state should be
resolved through a liberal state
that kinda recognizes
those individual rights.
And again, they get linked
to party politics then
and they're politically engaged.
Now why is it important to
recognize this and inform?
I mean, what good does it do for us?
Obviously, there is intellectual
curiosity, but that's not just that.
Muslimism and in Turkey is probably
the most prominent or eligible actor
to promote a democratic secularism
that can balance tensions
between moral freedoms
and the secular state.
I mean, the secular state
historically had a tendency
to violate the rights of the
moral rights and moral freedoms,
but on the other hand, you know, you
don't want religion to [inaudible],
you know, the state either.
And, in fact, both enforcement
of religion and prevention
of religious rights is something
that Muslims are equally
burdened and offended with.
Also Muslimists are, you know,
if the religious expression can
promote a more progressive agenda
relation, and maybe most
importantly the rights of Muslimism
in Turkey is an alive example
of a counter narrative,
a living counter narrative
culture, alternative
and a counter narrative
to radical religion.
And it's coming from within.
It's not coming from, you
know, political strategies,
[inaudible] expediency
or market expansion.
I mean, it's theologically rooted,
so it's a very polite,
it's very powerful.
And Muslimistic impulses do not --
Muslimist is not only
unique to Turkey.
I could call it Muslimism
in the context of Turkey,
but we find impulses
of it in the region.
Even if for now they're politically
co-opted and haven't been able
to translate into political change,
those cultural sentiments exist,
they continue, and they in large
part explained the Arab attraction
to Turkey.
I don't think it was
simply because, you know,
they like the Prime Minister by
then, who's now the president,
but it was, you know,
the ability of Turkey
to live this hybrid life where, you
know, you have your Muslim identity.
You don't have to sacrifice from
it, but you can still, you know,
swim or engage a liberal state or,
you know, engage public debate.
So what of the future of Muslimism?
Of course it's historically
contingent.
I mean, when you say religion
as culture that also means look,
you know, different
conditions are going to result
in I mean it's a very simple formula
in different religious expressions.
And it's possible at any point
it may turn into Islamnism
or become liberal religion.
It's quite vulnerable actually
to turn into liberal religion,
but maybe through questions
we'll talk about that.
So domestically party
politics will be effective,
turn to an authoritarian state or
an Islamist state will bode ill
for the Muslims form Kurds.
Economy and middle-class how is
Turkey going to handle and from now
on the peace process with the Kurds.
Economy and middle-class,
and external conditions,
security threats, Syrian
immigration, Islam severe relations
with the West because
when you look back
at the 80's the international
contacts are very conducive
for this type of religious
expression to emerge,
but it seems right now that it's the
international context is actually
promoting the otherwise.
So one last thing, again,
I said that Muslimism was
not only unique to Turkey.
In fact, it's not only unique
to Islam, which is the concept
of new religious orthodoxy
is actually more global.
It's the potential
general type of engagement.
In particular it may be
helpful to categorize US
and evangelicals after 1980's.
Christian Smith, for example, a very
prominent scholar on evangelicalism,
what differentiates evangelicals
is their ability, unlike liberal
and fundamentalist movements
to maintain both difference
from an engagements
with American society.
This is actually what we have
discussed Muslimism, you know,
of doing like it doesn't reject
modernity, it doesn't submit to it,
but it create some
verticalar model maybe.
So I want to finish
with this picture.
So the girl on my left.
I think it's to your right, the
one's taking the photograph.
I met her very recently again
through the company work
and she is the only word
journalists that is a hijab
and she's a Turkish female.
And she took this picture in Syria
when she was there recently going
through the, you know,
Isis regions and so.
And so she's wearing a hijab, as you
can see, and we don't even have many
like female or journalists and
this girl is a devout Muslim.
She's wearing the jihab and
she's a word journalist.
And she's taking a picture
of this other female.
I like you to look at her shoes.
I mean, this picture to me was
very moving, because you have,
you know very clearly you can
see that hijab doesn't have
to meet one thing, right .
I mean, in one case you have a word
journalist, I mean, more progressive
than most secular woman that I
know, right, that goes to war.
By the way, she is
married and she has a kid.
Like, her kid is four years old
and she's going to Iraq next month.
And you see this other woman
also hijab, but I mean,
I know from the story that
this other girl doesn't want
to cover her face, but she has
to because that's, you know,
the external authority
wants her to do that.
So I think I'm done here [laughs].
That's it.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much Neslihan
for illuminating this
very fascinating sights
of hybridity in Turkey and beyond.
I think we have a few
minutes for questions.
And again, I just like to state
that if you can limit your questions
to just a few thoughts
on the program itself.
And also know that since
we're videotaping this,
you're giving your
permission to be recorded.
So will entertain a few questions.
Eve, I see your hand.
>> Well, yeah, I wanted to
make a very quick comment
about seeing these very young women
these days are very stylish hijabs.
There seem to be a
whole range of styles
of now wearing a really cool hijab.
But yesterday I saw a family in
which the father was in a T-shirt
and jeans and, you know,
looked like a hipster
and the wife was in a full hijab
They were putting the baby in a
car and I'm wondering is it easier
for those types of hybrid families
[inaudible] very traditional
[inaudible] to exist in less
or is it accepted in Turkey
and other countries
beyond to have [inaudible]?
>> I mean it's not a
matter of maybe exception,
it's a matter of them practicing.
I suppose what they think
they should be doing.
In Turkey I can tell
you this though.
In Turkey you don't
have the abaya [phonic].
Like the abaya has never --
I mean we have people who are
wearing the pecha [phonic],
you know, like the face thing
and that, you know, black.
But they're mostly belong to a
certain camaat or a certain tahqiq.
In Turkey since the '70s, since the
'60s Islamic textile industry has
been a bit more diversified
than what we find in Gulf region
and Turks don't cover their
face, most of them don't.
In terms of the veils, you have a
lot of different immigrants right,
so it may be a family
that is more adherence
like that has a more traditional
conception of what the hijab is
and who the self is and how
the community should work.
And I should mention I was
having a conversation with one
of the previous congressmen
of the Welfare Party,
which is more [inaudible] with,
you know, I suppose they had more
of an Islamist discourse
than Muslimists.
And then for him the hijab was
something that defined the limits
of the community, so it wasn't and
that's this is really problematic
because you wear hijab because, you
know, you think that it's God's,
you know, requirement of you
that you think it's farce.
But for the man it also
had an ideological purpose.
It had the purpose of separating all
sources them Muslims from others,
so maybe that's family
comes from that type
of theological rating
whereas the other one comes
from a different theological rating.
so that's the main thing, though.
Like, you know, religion
is articulated differently
by different ages.
That doesn't mean that
there is a variety of Islam.
I mean, there is one Islam
and Muslims are Orthodoxial.
Yeah. I hope that that helped.
>> Thank you very much
for your time.
Could you give us the
names of some leaders --
[ Inaudible ]
>> Right. So, okay.
The one thing Muslimists
are not a formal movement.
They don't have, you know, bulletins
or newsletters and so forth,
but it's more of a
cultural movement.
And when they meet with each other
they recognize on those movements,
but the sights that I studied
for example included Capital
Woman's Platform, Muslim Dash,
a human rights organization.
Misiat, one of the biggest Muslim
economic business [inaudible]
in Turkey and Justice
and Development Party,
but that was when I interviewed
them that was in their second term
and things kind of have
changed since 2010.
So, yeah. I can write down
those names for you after.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yeah.
>> So we have some more questions?
Well, I just had one [inaudible]
I was thinking through it.
I know in Turkey for so
many times there was kind
of if you ask somebody can you go
ahead and do this commit to this,
there was always kind of the
[inaudible] I hope for it, you know,
kind of self predetermined whether
you would be able to do it or not.
And how would you think free
will is emerging kind of concept
of critical thinking
about how you're going
to do things would work out?
>> I mean, that's one
of the central questions
that had Islamic theologians fight
with each other and even, you know,
accuse of each other for
being [inaudible] try
to detect their meaning, you know,
taking someone out of religion.
It's a tricky question, but so the
thing is but what I mean when I say
"agency," it's not the agency.
It's not, you know, opposed to
this idea of predestination,
plus even when there is
predestination you still have
a choice.
I mean and [inaudible] for examples
our prophet is doing [inaudible]
and he has an abaya on him and this
poor man is standing there like,
you know, really poor, whatever.
And then he looks at the prophet
and he thinks within himself, oh,
I should sell that because now
he's going to do [inaudible]
and he can't move so
I should steal it.
Meanwhile the prophet is
thinking I should give my abaya
to this poor man, so I think
I mean, I'm not a theologian.
I mean, I read theology,
but I'm not a theologian,
so the idea is the predestination
here is that the guy is going
to get the abaya, whether he can get
it through stealing it or through,
you know, prophet's
blessing that's his agency.
Now when it comes to another example
that I've encountered
throughout my, you know, research.
I was talking to the guy who
owns, he was the sector chair
of automobile industry
at [inaudible]
and then he was telling
me this, you know,
one time this camaat had
took the and the mom comes in
and he wants to buy a car.
And I tell him, "Well, if you're
buying the car buy insurance."
He was like, "No, I had insurance.
I can't like it's the faith.
I can't buy insurance."
Then he makes an accident and
then he comes back and say, "Okay,
well can you give me insurance now?"
[Laughs] So, I mean, the thing is
like all those concepts are being
so misunderstood too like the
whole Koran, like you have to have
as an individual you're responsible
to choose between good and bad
and that doesn't mean that you
like you have agency there.
You have to have agency.
So also it's important to
differentiate the agency I'm talking
about isn't towards God himself.
I mean, it's not preached from God,
it's the agency towards the head
of a camaat or towards a
state, whether Islamist
or secular state I think.
>> Anybody else, question?
Okay. Mohammed.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Yes, no, that's very true and so
when I was doing my this what you're
suggesting, like what you're saying
in terms of like, you know,
this is becoming recently --
I mean, this is a very
recent development.
Back in when I was doing this
research this is not the case.
I mean, today Dolce and Gabbana and
Tommy Hilfiger, Mongo, all of them,
Donna Karan, did I say that?
All of them has invested
in the Islamic markets.
Why? Because the markets are
calculated to be $469 billion
in 2020, so there's a
lot of money to be made.
And so, but this is
actually precisely the moment
where we should talk
about how the emergence
of hijab fashion has been filtered
through theological concepts,
because now everybody looks at
there's consumers and it's just,
you know, Muslims are being
engulfed by capitalist markets.
So markets are finally
converting Islam into vanity,
into consumerism, secular
as orthodoxy.
But what I found with the
early adopters, let's just say,
because those women were in their
40's and they were the first ones
in Turkey by then kind of like to
adopt this kind of like discourse
about fashion and personalization
of the aesthetics of hijab.
And there's was not simply
about looking more trendy.
It was about being able to.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I mean another thing,
like the one
who covers the Saudi Arabia
wears a bikini in Miami,
so I mean it's about your rights.
Many reasons for women
some of them do jihab
because in their community it's
easier to find a husband that way.
>> Or a job [inaudible].
>> Or a job, but that's not about,
I mean, this question is kind
of like it brings back the state
and community and organizations
and the society back
into our plates, right?
So if you're not allowed
to [inaudible] job
in a country you're going to
wear is whether you want it
or whether you don't, but that
doesn't take out of the authenticity
of the job or itself or why our
people now or the legitimacy
of the question and the
interest of the question
of what is the hijab fashion mean?
You know what I mean?
So that's different, but,
yeah, I mean people do that.
Some do hijab because they
think that that's partisan
and they're more, you know,
knowledgeable on it and they see it
as a partisan part of the orthodoxy
and some does it for
traditional reasons.
>> I want to thank Neslihan and
again for a wonderful presentation
that specially celebrating women's
history month at the Library
of Congress illuminating
a lot of new concepts
of how women are modernizing
in Muslimism.
Thank you very much Neslihan.
>> You're welcome, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.